hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to slime rancher boink
Oh nope
oh boy boink boink boink oh god I'm
terrible I did that perfectly before
everyone ignore my failure I'm gonna
start this episode over hey hello
everybody my name is markiplier Boing
Boing Boing Boing boy wow what a
distance I got news on I'm still a
little sick I've got a bad throat thing
hey you're not supposed to be out get
back in there kidding oh my god I am
doing terribly here aren't I ok so
there's gotta be I'm gonna just make
another Corral here because this is not
working out I mean these buggers can fly
how's that even gonna be fair alright
whatever point 1 boink boink boink uh
excuse you don't fornicate with the
wrong slime sigh God how much what are
you how'd you get here god dammit they
made it already and they made a butt
baby ah screw em ok so yeah those are
those are able to fly how it said even
could be possible okay so this is a
problem but I need to collect more poop
to be able to make more Corral's because
I can only house like a few of them at a
time in a pen or else you're just gonna
get out and go everywhere not that
that's necessarily a bad thing so long
as they keep eating and pooping I mean
so long as we keep the entire economy
that's based on poop going there cat
they deserve to be free anyway can I
capture these guys another thing I can
do oh maybe not uh diet slime meats and
okay so those are obviously the bad guys
Oh Oh God oh I didn't know oh lordy
laughs no don't get me man I didn't even
watch them die before I don't even know
why I would want to watch them die
before but that's that was much more
horrific than I thought it would be so
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna assemble some
food here so that I can eventually feed
them the stuff that they need at my farm
because out here in the wild it seems to
be kill or be killed there is no mercy
to be found anywhere also I could give
this guy some food I don't know what
this guy's gonna give me but there's an
ample supply food beside him and he's
kind of adorable to be honest I mean in
his own little way I got a lot of Pogo
fruit here blurr hold my brother Lord
Lord Lord blur blur blur blur blur blur
goddamn blue blend blend blend
all those probably a big waste on my
part I need not have done that I need
not have done anything in relation to
that can you get mushroom split nope
okay Gordo just sits there with his
mouth open a gape and ready for anything
to enter it don't take that in any
horrifying way that you were thinking of
right now and you've gone to the dirty
places in the reaches of your mind thank
you everybody so much for meeting my
expectations on everything about that
okay so now that everyone's happy and
somehow is respawned over here I guess
that's are collecting rooster Oh struts
his stuff god damn it I was gonna get
that chicken at least you pooped out
some money for me so at least I get that
thank you
I didn't even get to read with the rest
of the thing whoa sorry everybody I've
got a bad cough I'm trying to get rid of
it but it just ain't happening I've got
two cough drops in my mouth at the
moment not that I need to w they update
you guys on what exactly was in my mouth
but just in case you could hear
something clacking in there you know
what I'm gonna ignore that okay hello
can you give me some more poop god
damnit I need them not you whoa Jesus I
only wanted the poop thank you bro hello
are you the one that hurt me before
probably yeah fudge get off of me I
didn't god dammit
I need that poop I needed to fuel all my
money concerns I have a mortgage to pay
for don't eat that poop thank you sir
well so what does this do Oh Oh God Oh
oh my goodness hello you're gonna get
eaten in no time flat there's so many
things in this game that I don't
entirely understand just yet but I'm
gonna get to it eventually
eventually I'm gonna be good at this
game ooh what does this sign mean beyond
this point lies nothing but death okay
I'll go this way ooh what is that square
fruits goodbye goodbye chicken I'm so
sorry
I could have deposited you on the land
right here but I didn't feel like it
it inconvenienced me far too much to be
bothered by the likes of that also yes
this shirt I'm wearing is very hot I
need to change out this is a bit too
much for me
oh god it's hot I like to order a lot of
clothes from Korea not because I am
Korean which I am but I
just because I find it interesting a lot
of the styles that they have so I like
to order them but I got to remember that
in the winter here in LA
Eddie's blazing hot compared to how it
is in Cincinnati back in my hometown and
the rest of my life that I've
experienced requires a sign key I don't
know what a slinky is whoa that is a big
kitty I'm gonna go say hi to the kitty
cat hello
oh you're another one that needs food
maybe I can get the keys from you guys
damn it I had all that food I could have
made one month's yeah so like I was
saying I'd like to order a lot of
clothes from Korea not because I'm too
big into fashion if anyone knows me in
real life and anyone has seen me I am
NOT into fashion I am NOT fashionable in
any way I am NOT cool I'm not hip I'm
not happening I'm not it with the kids
whatever it may be I'm a loser it's
pretty much long short in my life but I
do like the interesting sounds of the
have in Korea but oftentimes buying from
there it takes forever to ship and
goddamn it is weird clothes that they
give you one carrot great I've got a
cube berry and nothing else how do I get
more inventory space because this is
starting to be [ __ ] it's the land of
poop oh my god it's the land of infinite
poops oh I'm gonna have so much money
sorry for spiraling you off into death I
guess see maybe I could just deposit all
the pink slimes here because I don't
need them in my farm I have enough pink
I have enough pink in my life in general
I don't need more you none of you get
sucked up in my suck gun please oh I can
only carry 20 these that time No
Oh God if wreak havoc on the poor
innocent chickens oh we're living here
in peace oh I thought the slimes on to
them I'm so sorry chickens I'm not sorry
at all cuz it means more poop money for
me now let's see if I can actually make
this shot from a long distance like I
was trying to do at the beginning of
this episode not that you saw my utter
failure but uh you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah there we go that's the
stuff
I'll see that's barely any money man
it's not even worth having the pink
slimes when everyone else is calling
gonna get meme way more money jeez I
should just get rid of all the pink ones
I should just keep the tabbies oh hello
I didn't even know it no it's my harvest
give me those I need to give them to the
bot stop it I need to give him to the
special ones
you guys aren't special enough to
deserve this food I'm not man I don't
want to scoop up your poop I want to
scoop up the special glowy poop that's
what really makes me happy in life you
love a very sad person I don't what is
this
ooh star mail oh I didn't even know this
oh this would have been great if I'd
known what I was doing before I started
this game allow me to introduce myself I
am Victor Humphreys professional slime
ranchers I'm scientists an amateur
musician my understanding is that miss
West has already informed you of how the
range exchange works so I'll spare you
any further education Thanks it wouldn't
be good to know what I'm doing here out
in the wilderness where slimes eats
lines and slimes eat chickens and
chickens eat nothing instead I'll
eliminate you on what you didn't expect
from my own regrets as a flying around
okay ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba good
luck in your future what oh okay hi oh
that was the last one oh whoops
okay so basically all this says is shove
poop in machine money go fall out which
is fine by me I suppose I don't even
know much more than that
I want to know where that golden poop
comes from because that's what I really
want to hold up all right get out of
here you pink douches pretty common
what is this what cool oh I could have
been shoving my aw that's cool I didn't
even know there was a trading system oh
I would give up all my side I do not
have that many glowy slimes but I'll do
my best I guess
come here come here come here come here
come here hey hey come here
uh-uh-uh-uh damn it three short where am
I gonna get more pink slums
I have no goddamn idea oh look more pink
slimes what is you oh you're so cute
no oh they're filled with marshmallows
and that's probably why they get eaten
ooh no no I thought it was gonna eat the
little guy oh man it's so sad his wife
just got devoured right in front of him
and he doesn't even care here have a
baby I guess I could try to fill that
big bellies more what is this
boink hello thank you I guess I guess I
was just randomly spawned throughout the
world which is cool I should keep an eye
out them for them probably but I won't
because I'm not very good at the game
yet but I'm getting there
mm-hmm all right eat your food oh geez
how much food does this guy need oh come
on
Jesus it's not fair Oh grow faster you
do she's right I'll be back
can you guys provide more blue poop
that's what I really like not that I
have a never mind I mean he's getting
pretty big he's getting pretty sizeable
blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop
oh oh oh oh he's gonna help whoa oh god
no no oh come on
Oh what the hell are they oh hey I got a
key oh look at me I saw first
I got his heart in the shape of a beet I
fed him until he exploded that's a
little bit her if ik I got what I needed
then and I have a slime key and I know
exactly where to put this key ah I could
for me how about a little bit hey whoa
all righty then for some reason I
thought like a flower blooming from a
rocky crack this emerald expands hints
at what could be e okay what do you mean
by that
am i doing good is this do good is this
me do goo
oh hey oh now that's cool oh hey whoa
whoa hey whoa whoa stay a little hey hey
oh god they're all integrated oh man
oh no oh god is that time already damn
it I thought I was gonna be okay I
thought I found the land of milk and
honey I found the land of death and
destruction Oh God okay let's just
meander over here oh wow
where the hell am I can they fight back
now oh are you Golden's oh I'm gonna get
rid of the pink ones I'm gonna collect
these golden slimes cuz I have a feeling
whoa
honey slime that's okay with me I can
deal with this if I collect a rare slime
then I'm gonna be able to take the roush
lines home take care of them and that'll
be way better than just farming off of
the pink forever hello you're not what I
wanted I could do without that thrust in
your slimy body up against my camera
thank you ha okay so I'm over here now
which is kind of cool cuz I can kind of
make it over here yeah okay so maybe
this can lead back around at the
beginning and then I can get back home
cuz god damn I'm a long way from home
well [ __ ] that left exactly where I
didn't need to go well they lingered for
me it's kind of your way I don't think I
can make that that's a bit of a distance
ooh I would lose everything if I died
didn't wouldn't
who's gotta be another way yeah yeah now
we're game breaking now or breaking the
system now we're doing it okay this is
definitely not where I'm supposed to be
ooh eh they look like they're having fun
can I suck one up from over here I've
got maximum suckage potential but it's
just not cover in the distance okay
so that'll do it for this episode I've
gone quite a while and I've probably
gone where I shouldn't be so that's
exactly what I wanted to do so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'll
figure out what to do from here in the
next episode but thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye you are
walking along minding your own business
example